et pour michel scarbonchi ancien député
européen il est bon pour la france comme
pour le royaume-uni qu'un accord était
trouvé en se réveillant de ré je pense
que la pression française et notamment
les déclarations du président macron
relatif au fait que la france exercerait
son veto en cas d'accord qui ne
stipulerait pas ne contiendrait pas lui
même un accord concernant la pêche a
pesé beaucoup dans la balance et a
permis d'aplanir un certain nombre de
problèmes qui se posaient depuis de
longs mois puisque cela fait près près
de dix mois que nous sommes en
négociations avec la grande-bretagne et
donc il est heureux qu'en ce jour de
noël enfin une bonne nouvelle pour
l'europe et même pour la grande bretagne
parce que de toute façon s'il n'y avait
pas eu d'accord c'était perdant-perdant
pour l'europe et perdant perdant pour
les britanniques
donc il faut se féliciter de cet accord
très important qui va permettre de régir
les règles entre la grande bretagne et
l'union européenne et qui va permettre
probablement de continuer à considérer
la grande bretagne comme un partenaire
dans tous les domaines même s'ils ne
sont plus dans l'union européenne